a lot goes into making a movie
especially one in the sprawling Marvel
Cinematic Universe and sometimes
directors don't get things quite right
on the first go-around such as the case
for Avengers endgame and filmmakers John
Anthony Russo who brought back Tilda
Swinton to be shooter seen more than a
year after she rapped on it that's right
we haven't exhausted every possible
endgame topic I understood that
reference a movie of this magnitude is
chock-full of behind-the-scenes secrets
spoilers ahead Swinson who plays the
ancient one appears during a pivotal
moment in the middle of endgame when
Professor Hulk and company traveled back
in time to 2012 New York City to
retrieve three Infinity stones as part
of their time heist mission the green
guy pays the ancient one a visit at the
sanctum sanctorum and that's er to
surrender the time stone wall ant-man
Captain America and Iron Man are off
retrieving the space and mine stones
professor hawk is on the receiving end
of a lecture about how one can't just
take an infinity stone out of its proper
place without severely damaging the
existing timeline it's an important
scene that establishes how time travel
works in the MCU but it's a scene that
originally played out differently
chatting with indieWIRE Swinton revealed
that the Russo brothers caught her into
film the sequence all over again a year
after she first shot her Swinton
explains I went back to reshoot it
because a couple of lines have been
changed a couple of plot points have
been changed and there was a tweaking of
my costume as it's expected Swinton
couldn't dish up exact details and what
the original take entailed though she
did state that the reworked plot points
were all about the visual timeline the
ancient one Krauss when explaining to
Professor Hulk that rules of time-travel
and alternate realities she then noted
that the alteration centered around
quotes the information that the ancient
one holds about the nature of the
Infinity stones they have to be put back
in the theatrical cut of the film the
ancient one goes into great detail about
how the timeline is impacted when
someone takes an infinity stone from one
point in time and transports it to
another that kind of interdimensional
tomfoolery creates a branch timeline
that is dark chaotic and doesn't abide
by the same laws that the original
timeline does this has phonation informs
the avengers decision to have one team
member Captain America
return the stones after they defeat
Thanos at the end of the film Swinton
also said that the Russo brothers
changed up the dialogue in her scene to
better connect two ends games shooting
down time-travel rules presented in
movies like back to the future and
Ted's Excellent Adventure y Clinton also
gushed about her experience working on
endgame and said that the double shoot
was more than worth it that was amazing
and a whole other world of filmmaking
but boy was it worth it
they tweaked it into something
extraordinary time travel we may never
know what the original version of the
sanctum sanctorum sequence and endgame
was like but it sounds like the reshoot
added some much-needed clarity to the
film fans have had a hard time wrapping
their heads around how time travel works
within the context of the MCU in general
that's a dumb question okay got it so we
all agree it's possible now what and how
time travel works and ends games
specifically even with the reshoot so
it's a good thing the Russos summons
when turned back to the set check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more loop of videos about the MCU
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]